[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
this is a good one especially if you're
a woman if you're a man you also will
learn a lot too we definitely sprinkle
that in or if you want to understand
your woman better we get into
conversations about birth control so you
might want to know that information but
Dr Stacy Sims is an exercise
physiologist and she's a nutrition
scientist so I've been listening to her
for a while now and every time I listen
I learn something new she's so smart she
understands a woman's body from a
biological standpoint hormonal
standpoint recovery exercise nutrition
she's just so well informed and you know
they're just so few and far between
those who understand the woman's body
really well because well at the end of
the day they're not well researched I
mean they were using male rats for
breast implants it's just crazy see how
under represented women are from a from
a study perspective to know exactly
what's going on with the body so today
was it was just really really thorough
conversation on everything around eating
refueling
fueling for the workout when to train
how to train what time of day where to
get your most bioavailable proteins
split training for body recomposition
what the most effective way is to lose
weight I learned so much today and going
to apply that into my life now so I hope
that is the same for you and we could
just start to understand a woman's body
better and her famous statement is that
women are not small men and you're going
to hear that today okay thanks for doing
this I'm yeah I'm connected with so much
of your stuff and like I've been through
such my own health Journey over the last
couple of years and so anytime that
someone's talking especially in
particular to women's health and women's
hormones and training and
just how to refeed and just all the
different things that it takes to be
healthy I'm so tuned in because
I feel like what I was doing in my
mid-30s that worked and it did work for
a while just isn't wasn't sustainable
like two a day is like low carb like
probably generally low calorie
um you know just High all high intensity
I mean even the second workout would be
an interval workout it wasn't like just
some super low impact something
um and I just between that and you know
changing jobs changing relationships
changing where I live just so many
different things I just my the whole
system just went I hate you and
everything just shut down and it really
all kind of launched by me losing my
cycle which is such an ultimate
indicator of General Health for a woman
um if you're in the reproductive years
and so I went to the doctor and the
first thing he said which was like I
thought oh my God this is it it'll fix
everything he's like oh your thyroid is
really low and I'm like there it is
that's it this explains the weight gain
this explains uh you know being a little
more lethargic this explains just so
much oh my gosh everything's gonna be
better and I just thought this magic
pill was going to be everything and that
was
April of 2021 and it's now early 2023
and I'm literally
about six about four weeks into feeling
like oh my God my body finally is
responding yeah that long and that many
things doing everything from NAD to
hyperbaric chamber to
peptides to elimination diets to gut
protocols to I mean I did everything and
anything you could possibly imagine to
try and do it I mean fasting
lenses uh
cutting out alcohol you name it like any
anything that could possibly work so
anyway I think this is just an important
conversation I'm not going to do much
talking from here on out
um but I just think that women's
hormones are just you know and and a
woman's system is just so much more
intricate I want to say the word
complicated and I think that is true but
it at least it's much more intricate and
there's a lot more to it and um and it's
a it's a puzzle and I just want to do
anything I can to give women the
opportunity to put the puzzle pieces
together and have control of their body
and their life again and
um or maybe learn about it for the first
time so
maybe I think the first question is like
what are some of the most detrimental
things that
um that a woman can do to and if there's
a part where a man fits into this fine
but yeah really coming at this from my
perspective
um what are some detrimental things that
women need to be on the lookout for like
or even Trends in the last 10 15 years
that
um that are really something to con to
question
uh so when I first heard your story the
first thing I said was in my head was
red s relative energy deficiency in
sport because people often diagnosed
with thyroid dysfunction but then they
have gut issues they have weight gain
they have bone issues stress reactions
mental health issues cardiovascular
issues and it's that big picture and
Physicians don't know it
so I'd say some of the biggest
detrimental things have come out in the
trends is intermittent fasting fasted
training
the ketogenic diet
um
uh some of the continuous high intensity
when it's not properly high and people
don't understand that it's just putting
them in a tired moderate intensity State
um and so those would be the big ones
that have been the trends really and so
when I'm looking at it and and hearing
your story and I hear it a lot as well
it's like okay because all the stuff
that gets pushed out into the fitspo
media into popular media even into
things like the well and good articles
it's all based on male data so if we
take something like fasted training and
we see you know we're supposed to become
more quote metabolically efficient and
burn more fat in men yes but in women we
know women do better in a Fed State
because our metabolism during exercise
is different so we don't have to train
to become more metabolically efficient
or have flexibility because our bodies
are already there by the nature of being
born XX or xxy and we have estrogen
progesterone so when we start really
digging into the pieces and I hear so
many women who are you know I don't
understand what's happening I'm doing
all the things right but I'm really
tired I'm putting on belly fat I can't
hit my intensities I'm tired but wired
so when we start to unpack it and
understand oh they're doing fasted
training or they're doing intermittent
fasting not particularly time restricted
eating because there's a difference
there and they're doing nothing but high
intensity high intensity high intensity
and lots of resistance training it's
like okay we have to stop pause unpack
it let's see how old you are are you on
an oral contraceptive pill or not I mean
naturally cycling what are those Cycles
like if you're in your 40s or Beyond we
really have to unpack it because we have
to understand are you perimenopausal yet
or not when is that coming and it's a
lifespan because men age in a linear
fashion so all the data we see on Aging
all the data we see on metabolism it's
all based on this linear model where men
just kind of tickle long and they age
and they don't have a discernible set
point where all of a sudden boom their
testosterone just plummets but for women
we have it when we hit perimenopause and
we start seeing changes in our estrogen
or progesterone it's a discernible point
where women start to age and no one
tells them what's going on so then you
hit that one point in time menopause and
they're like oh my God what has happened
can you delay that is this a biological
Rhythm that is out of your control when
you hit perimenopause and then
essentially menopause or can your
lifestyle and sort of taking care of
your hormones properly can that delay
that process
no you can't delay it but you can
definitely make it better
because when we look at all the
conversations around what you should do
for perimenopause and the 150 minutes of
moderate intensity exercise and two days
of resistance training all that standard
stuff does not work for women who are in
their early to mid 40s onwards and I say
that I see your face and I say that
because we're looking at that modern
intensity that's exactly the area of
exercise intensity women don't want to
be in when they're experiencing changes
in their hormones because when we have a
drop in progesterone we end up in a
greater sympathetic drive so this is why
I say you know women are always saying
I'm tired but wired and we have a
greater Baseline level of cortisol
because the body's under extreme stress
so when we put ourselves in that
moderate intensity which also falls into
things like the orange theory the f45s
boot camp classes then you end up with
this greater cortisol and there's
greater sympathetic Drive which then
stimulates the body to put on more body
body fat and you never really get into a
parasympathetic good sleep pattern you
don't recover very well and you get into
this well what's going on I'm going to
start restricting calories because I'm
putting weight on which then pulls them
into low energy availability and it's as
a vicious cycle yep yeah that's totally
I mean that was me like it all probably
started when I was about 36 7
and kind of kept going down and I just
kept thinking actually the first thing
that hit me is I was like I wonder if
it's my hormones and then I just did
what an A type a person does I just said
try harder and so you work out more and
you eat less and it just all continues
to spiral and so that that spiraled for
a good four years
before I finally sort of
I don't know what seems like has been
the the solution is
um and I want to talk about the training
after this
um
changing my workouts to being pretty
much just strength training three days a
week every other day and then on those
every other days with still one full day
off is just like 40 minutes of super
easy low intensity like just like
walking uphill
um and then also dropping my fat to kind
of still keep calories in check
um and upping my carbohydrates a lot
like and complex not like fibrous not
just all fibrous like vegetable based
um carbohydrates but rice and sweet
potatoes and stuff that I was generally
avoiding
um does that sound like the reason why
things were getting back on track or is
there still issues within those sort of
shifts because I'm 40. one you're
probably in low carbohydrate
availability and a lot of women are
afraid of carbohydrates because of all
the messaging right don't have bread
don't have potatoes don't have rice none
of this
but women need carbs and if we have a
low amount of carbohydrate availability
then our brain perceives it as low
energy density so it starts to conserve
and we see after four days of this your
thyroid starts to take a hit so you end
up in the low end of normal it's the
first thing that happens so if you go to
the physician and they're like oh you
have low thyroid instead of trying to
dig a bit more and look at like
luteinizing hormone pulse is that off
what about estrogen progesterone what's
going on there they're like oh you have
hypothyroidism here's here's some pills
let's try that yeah but if we take a
step back and go okay well let's look at
carbohydrate availability let's up
carbohydrate especially in around
training then the hypothalamus is like
hey sweet there's fuel here for this
training stress and there's fuel still
available for me to do all the things I
need to do including keeping a healthy
endocrine system so your thyroid doesn't
take a hit and one of the things that we
have found in research is that even if
you aren't eating enough calories but
you are book ending your training with
adequate carbohydrate and protein your
hypothalamus doesn't perceive you as
being in a low energy state
so when we look for like athletes or
recreationally really competitive people
who are trying to drop a little bit of
weight we really make sure that we have
that nutrient timing nailed down and
then we can afford to have a calorie
deficit without impacting hormones and
without impacting sleep
so it has to do with that stress for men
they can get away with not necessarily
doing nutrient timing because when we
look at carbohydrate and calorie
sensitivity for men it's around 15
calories per kilogram of fat-free Mass
before they start having endocrine
dysfunction but for women we know that
you start to have a disruption around
30. so women's threshold is completely
different from men so we have two areas
in the brain in the hypothalamus that
read this and men have one so when
you're seeing thyroid dysfunction you
start seeing irregularities in your
menstrual cycle it's a hypothalamus
going hey wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait we have a problem here so this is
why I'm so adamant about women tracking
their menstrual cycles so that you can
have the opportunity to take a step back
when you start seeing these
irregularities and you can pull yourself
back before you get into significant
issues
well let's um let's talk about then
fasted training and you know again I'm
just going to be selfish and using
myself as an example correct
um I also
my training when I Strength train in the
morning for about an hour and 15 minutes
um is at like 6 45 in the morning and so
I don't eat before that and trust me
like I am not afraid to it's not a
problem
um I used to actually when I was you
know years ago when I would work out
later in the day I always ate first and
people go to the gym and they would have
not ate before I'm like how can you do
that I feel terrible if I don't eat
first
um so maybe that was some Saving Grace
along the way while I was super pushing
myself but
um but I don't right now and so
um I'm curious kind of how to go about
that and you know while still so like is
there any benefit to not eating before
you work out
for women not really we see that yeah we
see there's a blunting in your fatty
acid oxidation if you don't eat
and there is also a blunting in your
like muscle contractile strength so your
adaptations aren't as great either and
it doesn't take a lot like more looking
specifically at resistance training we
see that 15 grams of protein beforehand
significantly improves your ability to
hit what you need to during that session
does not blunt fatty acid oxidation
throughout the rest of the day and also
increases your Epoch or your excessive
post-oxygen consumption so your elevated
metabolism and it it's a favorable thing
that lasts for quite a few hours
afterwards not the same with just
carbohydrate
it's approaching that's really important
especially for resistance training if
you're going to do resistance training
and then like Sprint interval training
right after or any kind of
cardiovascular work you have to add in
some carbohydrate just to help with that
higher intensity from a cardio
cardiovascular standpoint I'm always
notorious for my protein coffee before
like I'd swam this morning and hence the
google eyes
so protein coffee it's like I have a a
double espresso that I make the night
before put in some almond milk scoop of
protein powder uh three grams of
creatine and boom out the door so I have
my protein I have a little bit of
carbohydrate from the almond milk and
then caffeine of course because I'm one
of those people that needs a shot of
coffee in the morning yeah I love coffee
is there a downside to coffee
not that we're aware of like it's not a
diuretic if you're someone who's a fast
metabolizer you might end up having too
much because you're like hey I like that
oh it's gone oh I want another one but
other than that not really so get 15
grams of protein in if your train
strength training and if you're adding
in a little bit of cardio at any point
um you want to add 10 or 15 grams of
carbohydrate we say about 30 30. yeah
okay
all up you're looking at maybe 150
calories total before you're doing a
strength and and cardiovascular type
workout otherwise it's around 100
calories from protein
okay well that a lot yeah that's more
than 15 grams though right I mean so
like 20 grams ish yeah five yeah so they
say 90 but who does 90 calories you're
like what's 90. we'll just round it up
yeah what's the role of fat because you
know fat you know fat coffee or
Bulletproof Coffee kind of thing has
been such a craze is fat uh detrimental
or is it just not helpful and so if
you're looking from a training
perspective it takes a really long time
to get out of your stomach and
intestines so it doesn't really fuel you
in any scope of the matter
the thing with Bulletproof Coffee and
all the things that they're like here's
your MCTS and your coffee it's for
satiation it's to help with that okay
let's get that cognitive focus and hold
that caffeine because it extends the
half-life of caffeine it also clears out
your blood sugar so you feel like you're
focused but really you're just on the
edge of being hypoglycemic and so it's
about the satiation and extending the
half-life of the caffeine yeah because
it is satiating it does curb your hunger
when I again like I said I did a lot of
fasting and I mean I was like 24 36 18
24 you know like doing like big fasts
and or what feels like big fast because
I don't like to be hungry
um it I mean coffee with a little bit of
fat or like a you know Nut Butter like a
like a cup like a fat cut fat bomb kind
of thing like that stuff would be like I
mean you could survive on 200 calories a
day or 300 just like because you've kept
enough fat in you to to say shape but
that makes sense with the caffeine to it
it extends that life okay just using me
as an example for morning workout people
what about afterwards with a refeed
timing like what kind of macros are more
important after specifics for strength
training when you are in your
reproductive years it's 30 grams of good
quality protein High leucine containing
protein when we start to hit light
perimenopause and menopause it's 40
grams because we have more anabolic
resistance so if we want to make the
strength training work for us we also
had to have a higher amount of
circulating amino acids post-exercise
and we see that it's a 30 to 45 minute
window after strength training to really
get that in for women for men it's a
different story because you see oh it's
not that important for the nutrient
timing for men but again it's because
the way that they come back down to
Baseline is different from women they
can hold off having
um food for up to two to three hours
before they really take a hit but for
women it's such a short window because
we come back down to Baseline so quickly
and then should it be more does the
carbohydrate or fat matter with fueling
after a workout for strength training
not so much but if we're looking at a
cardiovascular standpoint we look to get
about one gram of carbohydrate with that
30 grams of protein so one gram per
kilogram so what is that trying to
convert my head from metric to Imperial
so if it's one gram per kilo should be
half a gram per pound of carbohydrate
with your 30 grams of protein what about
out muscle synthesis is it called muscle
synthesis or protein synthesis when you
kind of have a certain amount of protein
every so often in the day there's like a
mechanism there what what is that yeah
so that's your muscle protein synthesis
or your mtor we look at regular
distribution throughout the day to keep
a certain amount of amino acids
circulating so that you're getting a
feedback that okay we're going to turn
it off then we're going to turn it on
then we're going to turn it off and then
we're going to turn it on I think this
is also where that conversation of well
you can't have more than 25 grams of
protein because it's not absorbed it
comes from which is not true we see that
there's a certain amount that will turn
on the mtor and anything above that
isn't that beneficial for muscle protein
synthesis okay but it is beneficial for
other things in the body like
neurotransmitter Health gut health where
other things are using amino acids so
when we're talking about like that 30
gram hit for women it's not that the
extra five grams isn't going to be
absorbed or it's going to be he turned
into fat that's complete BS we look at
it as like we need that extra leucine
that's coming from those 30 grams to
really tip over the amount of leucine
that's in the muscle to keep that mtor
working for women and the extra
essential amino acids that are
circulating is going to go for
neurotransmitter health or some of the
other aspects like within the gut or
nervous system now for men it's that 20
grams because that's all they need to
tip over that that mtor and yeah if
they're getting a little bit more again
they have more circulating for other
things
so and then if you do that it's like
four times a day is that or what is the
what is the magic formula to activate
mtor and what does mtor do
so mtor is
um
it is a protein that actually stimulates
the satellite cell to
develop and so this is where we're
talking about muscle protein synthesis
we're talking about the proteins that
develop into muscle cells got it so it
starts in the brain and feeds forward to
the muscle and so it's a feedback
mechanism we're looking at how to keep
that kind of even throughout the day we
say around 30 grams at each meal so
that's three times and then 15 grams at
each snack and then if you're training
hard then you're going to be altering a
little bit because there's a certain set
amount of protein that you want to get
in a day
that Baseline is about 1.1 grams per
pound especially as we get older and
then you can divide it up so you might
need to have a little bit more at your
meal you might look at having a little
bit more especially post exercise so it
depends on where you are and what you're
doing with your training as well as just
keeping it at regular intervals
throughout the day okay so a little bit
more with around training maybe a little
bit less otherwise and is there a
certain amount of meals in a day because
I feel like that's another that's
another area that's come and gone so
much is like you know lots of little
meals throughout the day to the theory
of just you know omad one meal or two
meals and having long long Windows of
you know time restricted feeding
um
what is what is best for I mean if you
want to cover cover the bases men and
women but definitely for for women in
general like what is what is the right
amount of meals to have in a day
I don't know if it's the right amount of
meals because that's kind of individual
but there's a lot of really cool
interesting research coming out about
your circadian rhythm okay and we know
that women's rhythms are a little bit
longer than men's so this is why we tend
to want to go to bed earlier and get up
earlier because our our circadian is a
little bit different than men's
so if we're looking at how
horizontal Peaks and drops and how our
hormones pulse and drop because it does
throughout the day we have pulses we
know that eating more up to about the
one o'clock period and then starting to
taper down and having a little bit more
of your carbohydrate scope
in the earlier part of the day and more
the protein scope towards the afternoon
is how it works with your body's Rhythm
and then when we get into people who are
like oh I've been doing time restricted
eating and I need to do this and then
it's like well first let's look at that
research has been done on rats has been
done on men and has been on done on OB
sedentary women but if you're really
hard and fast pulled to that rule then
stop eating after dinner and then eat
breakfast so you have a 12 hour window
overnight which is really called regular
eating but then you're also giving your
body a little break with your circadian
rhythm
so the best is I I mean that's probably
the most common I fasting just isn't my
favorite and
um it never has been but I tried and but
what feels logical is somewhere around
that 12 or 13 hours whatever that
circadian sort of more fasting window
um so is that is that something safe
that you can do all the time then yeah
absolutely because if we're looking at
like the big scope for health right we
see all these little Trends where you're
trying to
micromanage your body composition your
micromanaging how you feel but it's not
long term like if you're looking at long
term who can do time restricted or
fasting for you know your 16 hour fast
that kind of stuff right it's not that
sustainable for life so when we pull it
back down to more granular and we're
looking at the way that our body
responds to day and night and we see
that we have this circadian rhythm that
also changes across the seasons with
daylight we can stick to the pattern of
we our body needs more fuel when we are
awake to help with hormone to help with
cognition to help with Focus so when we
look at scoping that again like I said
carbohydrate up till you know around the
noon one o'clock and then a little bit
more protein not saying no protein and
no carbohydrate just the way you Scope
it and then it's at night time not
eating like because we've gotten out of
the habit of what it means to eat and
sit down and have a meal because you see
people eating in their car you have
people who are eating at dinner at 11
o'clock at night like they're we've lost
kind of not really the quote rules of
eating but we've become so disconnected
of what it means to be nourished and
it's like oh I'm eating because I'm
bored or I'm eating because I'm hungry
or I'm eating because my friend's eating
like we've become so disconnected so if
we think about it from like okay what
does my body need it needs energy now
and I need to sleep well so I'm not
going to eat two hours before bed
because I want a really good
parasympathetic response while I'm
sleeping and then I'm gonna wake up and
body's gonna need fuel so I'm going to
eat breakfast
that's just a general pattern that
everyone I think has lost in modern day
yeah yeah I yeah I agree and part of it
is so much mixed information absolutely
yeah um so then if we're if if you're if
you're gonna hold up to sort of that
12-ish hour window which is probably the
best for gut health and sleep as well
then you know take for instance me I
leave to go work out at 6 30 in the
morning so I'll want to back that up
from that sort of 15 20 grams of protein
that I have at 6 30 in the morning to 6
30 at night right or just that or does
that little bump in the morning not
really count oh it's looking at fuel for
some training that you're going to be
doing right it's not going to break into
all the health benefits and
parasympathetic response you have so
it's 12 hours or it's 11 hours but
you're just getting a good break between
10 and 12 hours where your body can kind
of rest digest get into parasympathetic
do the reparation it needs that happens
while you're sleeping consolidate
memories consolidate physical activity
stress all of those things it's just
when you're eating right before bed then
that stays in the system right and you
can't get into the parasympathetic that
you need to have optimal sleep
architecture more about sleep it's more
about the sleep and recovery and
parasympathetic state that your body
needs to get into so that you can
actually properly
um
refuel by sleeping right or you know
recover yep okay absolutely yeah I
understand let's finish off with some
supplements because I feel like this is
another area that gets again there's
just so much information about it
um you talked about creatine I had
actually never taken creatine until
about a week ago and then I started and
I had I just like it wasn't something
that anyone ever really recommended
highly it wasn't something that and I
feel like women get afraid of it because
I mean even my first instinct I was like
oh this is like is that water weight
like a little bit of like I was like oh
and women get scared of that but then
it's like no the whole point is is that
you put lean muscle must lean muscle
mass on and to have more you know or
better resting metabolic rate with the
amount of lean muscle mass you have and
you know even if it doesn't do anything
it goes further than that so creatine
has now been named by The Who as an
essential nutrient for women stop it
yeah oh my God something that scares so
many women is literally really an
essential and from what I've heard that
to get the right amount of creatine to
get the three grams or four or five or
whatever it is that you take you need
like a couple pounds of animal meat yeah
and I'm a vegetarian so I'm already
compromised right wow I know so when we
look at the research in Abby Smith Ryan
out of UNC has done a lot of research on
Creatine not only like in the sports
space but in the General Health space
across a woman's lifespan
so we see that it's essential for
pregnancy as well so when like no
supplements during pregnancy but
creatine is actually super beneficial so
when we look at creatine and what it
does it supports all the fast
bioenergetics in in the body so we're
looking at gut health and we're looking
at the mucosal membrane of our
intestines and for women we degrade it a
lot faster than men so this is why we
have greater incidences of GI distress
we look at brain health and mood and
there have been some really cool
clinical trials looking at SSRI and
creatine versus just SSRI and really
depressive episodes and women who are
adding creatine don't drop into the
significant really severe depressive
episodes and if they do they come out of
it really quickly because creatine is so
important for brain health and women
have 70 to 80 percent of the stores that
men have and then by the nature of not
eating as much or being more aware that
of the in impact of animal protein
they're not eating as much either so
they're really low in creatine so we
look at that three to five gram dose
it's not a massive dose a day and it's
not going to cause a lot of the side
effects that we get with the idea of
bodybuilding using creatine but what it
does it feeds forward to like you said
better muscular performance better lean
mass development but then we see better
mood better gut health better recovery
better immunity so all those things that
require a lot of fast accessible energy
is supported by creatine unbelievable so
every woman should take creatine every
day for
ever yeah either that or eat a lot more
meat it's not that you know any protein
and creatine might as well up the
chicken but no
um and then so what's the right timing
of that
it doesn't matter doesn't matter it's
just is it like isn't it like a muscle
saturation thing or something where you
just that's why you keep it up because
it
yeah so that's why we're like three gram
doses what is that a half half a
teaspoon a day yeah right that's not a
lot you can put it in any time and then
that increases muscle saturation
increases gut saturation brain
saturation everywhere so your body's
like yay I have some creatine I'm gonna
I'm gonna use it and make everything a
little bit better hell yeah okay great
well I'm glad it finally started then
um how soon does it take to see the uh
the benefits or the effects of creatine
and lean muscle mass and performance
so it takes about three weeks to really
really see and feel the difference not
that long but for mood you start to see
a difference in about a week yeah I've
never been this happy in my life there
you go two days are you two days in one
day yeah exactly like one week and it's
transformational screw all those other
supplements and adaptogens you just need
um okay what about BCAAs because I feel
like those are one too that you know you
hear definitely take it didn't make a
difference stupid doesn't work is it an
important thing as well or not so when
we're looking at Branch chain aminos if
we're looking for women to delay central
nervous system fatigue so say you wake
up and you've been traveling and you're
like uh I really want to do the strength
worth at workout but I'm just a little
bit flat if you use Branch chains it
supports central nervous system so you
can get through that workout as if you
weren't jet lagged so we use it
strategically in endurance
um endurance performance long stuff like
let's Gap your bottle with Branch chain
amino acids for the second half of the
race not only is it going to support
your body's metabolism by not eating
into your lean mass as much in this
endurance State also helps essential
nervousness and fatigue when we look at
it as a supplement to use through the
day to help with protein synthesis or
other things that they're saying we use
branched chains for it doesn't really
work you need all the essential amino
acids so if you're looking for a
supplement get eaas not just Branch
chains because if you're getting all the
essential amino acids the nine of them
together then they work together in the
system to actually do what they're
supposed to do so people are like well
if we talk about leucine so much maybe I
should just supplement with leucine it's
like no because you need the other ones
to actually leucine where it needs to be
and do what it needs to do
so it's good for energy sort of can help
that in an early morning workout if you
feel a little or just a morning workout
that you're feeling a little tired and
lethargic and other than that it can
help with I'm trying to see is there a
reason to take it later in the day no
sometimes if someone is vegan and
they're using pea protein isolate which
is just right there on the cusp of
having enough leucine for women
reproductively or sweet but when you get
into your 40s and onwards need a little
bit more so we're like Okay add some
fermented branched chain amino acids
just to boost the total amount of BCAAs
that are in there and then it all works
together so that would be the only other
time that you would do it
um and then like I said if you're doing
Iron Man marathoning all those Ultra
endurance type stuff you can look to use
it strategically in your training in
your racing to help with that second
half of fatigue or you know just like
need to focus
cool what about
um from a protein standpoint whey
protein P protein
collagen like uh what is the what what
are what are the most bioavailable
proteins
um for us to consume yeah so I love the
marketing that they're like collagen
protein because although they're amino
acids it does not work as protein the
way we think protein works because we
look at collagen there are three
specific amino acids that are tied into
a helix so we're looking at Native
collagen then this causes an immune
response and those peptide or those
helices are not absorbed so if you're
looking at Native or undenatured
collagen then it causes an immune
response which then tells the body not
to break down cartilage not to break
down as a native or non-denatured so is
there a specific kind of collagen that
is good
so then we look at peptides and they can
work together so if you're looking at
collagen peptides okay collagen peptides
are little bits of the whole collagen
that's absorbed but it goes to the
Target tissue it's not used for muscle
it's not used for amino acids in the
brain because they're so tightly tied
they go to like where the joint is
inflamed and it's like hey here's some
building blocks to kind of help with
that or the ligament or the skin or the
nails but it doesn't help with lean mass
so if you're let's say you're doing a
pre-workout not pre-workout pre-workout
but pre-workout protein and you're doing
your coffee then you don't want to use
collagen because that's not protein you
need 15 minimum you need at least 15
grams of protein so you'd need whey or
pea protein or something else yes so if
we look at the bioavailability of
proteins everything's measured against
the egg white so egg white sits about
100 we see and this is based on amino
acid composition and how how it is
absorbed by the body whey protein
isolate is 110. and then if we look at
whey concentrate which is often used in
a lot of the less expensive supplements
it sits at 80. we look at it so 100 is
perfect you're saying or 100 is just
like a how like a okay and so 110 is
better yeah the way Protein Isolate is
around 90 of bioavailable protein whey
protein hydrolyzate is about 95 so if
you're doing a scoop and it's like one
scoop is 22 grams of protein it's
actually 20 is going to be absorbed
from your way isolates is that what you
need to consider then when you are
considering taking in 15 grams of
protein before your workout let's say is
you need to think okay well this is not
going to be fully bioavailable so it
says 15 grams but I know I need to get
25 or something like that so that I get
enough protein to actually do the job
yeah that's why because it's really
confusing when you get into the weeds
like that I just tell people
use away isolate or away hydrolyzate and
you do the one scoop or the two
tablespoons of that and you're good to
go okay if you're vegan and you're using
pea protein isolate and we know that it
sits around 90. well we're going to use
two and a half tablespoons to make sure
that you get what you need so it's just
a little bit you need a a big heavy
scoop of pea protein isolate or just a
level scoop of whey isolate okay okay
what about beta alanine
beta alanine is interesting because it
does work in women it causes a
vasodilator response and it increases
muscle carnosine
but it doesn't have the same kind of
impact on performance that it does for
men so it's not as yeah it's not as
efficacious it does work do I just need
to double my dosage well no use it
strategically right so if you're like
okay I'm going in and I'm doing a really
heavy training session today and I want
to try to hit a few PRS or push a little
bit more
yeah then use it before
yeah
okay yeah and then the other one that
really is circulating is like beet juice
and nitrates right you hear everyone use
beet juice nitrates nothing for
Reproductive women doesn't work because
estrogen is really tightly tied to
endothelial function and the nitric
oxide cycle in our vessels so if you're
going to dose with nitrates
it doesn't necessarily read it and it's
like yeah there's no performance benefit
and sometimes there's a decrement
depending on if you're in high hormone
phase or not but we see in late
perimenopause and post-menopausal women
it's beautiful because we have less
vascular compliance we've lost estrogen
we need to have some kind of help in our
vasodilatory and constrictant response
using nitrates really helps and it also
helps attenuate hot flashes and night
sweats because the body has a better
understanding of getting rid of heat
through vasodilation and controlling
through constriction so we're looking at
almost putting it into a rhythm then
yeah yeah yeah so nitrate's great when
you're getting to the menopause
transition and you're in post-menopause
not great when you are in your
reproductive ears doesn't do anything
but beta-alanine you strategically don't
like load it and use it every day but
use it before a really hard workout to
be able to push a little bit more and
get a little bit more out of that work
out so is it like creatine that you need
to be consistent with it though is it so
you know just since like for me I only
train and I would think most people
don't hardcore train every day right
train every day so only do it on those
days it's just literally just to it's
essentially like a little bit of a
pre-workout yeah but you don't even have
to think about that so say you're
periodizing your training right and
you're like okay well I'm doing uh three
weeks working on my squat so I'm gonna
do
a one rep max for my squat you don't
want to use it for that one rep max
because you want a true representation
of that first one rep max and then you
go through a block of training right and
then you're like okay well here's real
I'm really loading because I want to get
a really good training effect maybe it's
the second week you're doing a lot of
cluster sets or you're doing heavy twos
use it then because the idea of training
is to create a stress that your body is
like I need to overcome this and get
stronger so you want to use it
strategically in that way and then when
you get to your third or fourth block
and you're like I need to do another one
rep max test don't use it because you
want to see what your true one rep max
is
um what about I've said the word
pre-workout and I know that can be a
popular thing for people is to get their
Pre-Workout in so is this just is this
just uh totally pointless is their wine
is it why not or are you just consuming
a whole bunch of long long word
ingredients for no reason
most of the pre-workouts all they are is
caffeine and ways to extend the caffeine
half-life
there are some really good
non-caffeinated pre-workouts that have
things like glutamine and Maca and
Rhodiola so you have your adaptogens
that help with focus it helps with
central nervous system you have
glutamine that helps with gut health so
those are the kinds of things that you
would want in a pre-workout because it's
supporting your physiology it's not like
making you so amped and Jack that you're
like oh I gotta hit it hard so we see
all these people are using these
pre-workouts and and some people end up
with really significant heart issues
because it's so much caffeine and
holding it it's like let's just it's
coffee and then pre-workout right yeah I
know and then coffee and you're yeah
yeah but I mean if if you're like I had
this pre-workout makes me feel really
great again you know periodize it phase
it in Phase it out like what are your
key workouts because people forget that
when you're going to work out it's for a
specific reason it's to hit certain
intensities it's to hit certain
workloads so that it's a really
significant stress on the body that
needs to then understand overcome to get
fitter so this is what I'm like if
you're doing cluster sets and you're
like I really need to eke out the last
two but if I don't have uh Branch chains
or I don't have my pre-workout then I'm
not going to get it but then you might
want to use it but I'm I'm the adjective
it's like okay let's put some Branch
chains in the drink bottle and let's use
some beta alanine before because then
you're controlling what you're taking
and you know what you're taking yeah if
you get a mix of pre-workout you're not
sure and you don't know what kind of
fillers and flow agents might also be in
there that can cause some issues right
right right so if you're if you're kind
of macro dosing your pre-workout you
take you take you know Branch chains you
take your beta alanine you get your 15
grams of protein in and you hit the gym
and you go crush it yep exactly okay all
right let's talk about crushing it
um workout's been something like oh my
God I mean I wrote a book called pretty
intense that was like
two days and all the intervals and high
intensity and none of the workouts were
too much longer than like 20 25 minutes
other than one a week and it's just like
you know that was just my thing but you
know I've just obviously learned so much
since then and I'm older you know and
I'm older so uh things just generally
kind of have their arcs so
um let's talk about the place for
high intensity
I mean I did CrossFit for so long so
like let's talk about where where that
kind of workout fits in and for who yeah
I just broke up with Crossfit a few
weeks ago it's sad isn't it like I loved
it I loved it but it just you know I
just I killed myself yeah it wasn't I'm
sorry rip CrossFit right now yeah well
not ripping it we're just saying like
there's a time and a place and then I
have women who are in their 40s and 50s
and they love it and they want to stay
in it I'm like okay but you have to make
each wad work for your body so you have
to go in with the decision that it's
going to be a heavy resistance training
day so you really maximize the strength
component and then just move during the
metcon cruise during the metcon don't
get competitive if you're a competitor
don't do it yeah I know it's so hard so
yeah it just wasn't working for me it's
like like I haven't done bar muscle ups
in a couple months but I'm sure I'll be
fine here I go yeah it's like I don't
need to do 30 bar muscle ups followed by
like like
finishing handstand push-ups followed by
you know all I'm like that's not
functional for my body it's going to get
me injured right um I love it but it's
just not right for for my body either
um but when we're talking about high
intensity this is where it gets a
misconception too we talk about true
high intensity interval training or true
high intensity there's the umbrella term
of hit and then you have Sprint interval
training in that as well okay yeah
so if we talk about Sprint interval
training this is 30 seconds or less of
supra maximal intensity so you're really
pushing the gas you're going as hard as
you can for 30 seconds and then you want
to fully recover it until you hit it
again and when you first start that you
might be able to do four or five of
those 30 seconds and then you can't do
any more and that's fine sure we talk
about hit or that high intensity
interval training this is where it goes
awry a lot of times because people are
thinking that these f45s or orange
theories or these boot camp like high
intensity classes at the gym is high
intensity but it's not because you can't
sustain high intensity for 45 minutes or
an hour so you fall into modern
intensity right so so true to redefine
high intensity interval training with
the correct definition it is an interval
that lasts from 30 seconds to the most
five minutes and it's between 80 and 95
of your max so if you're doing one
minute then it's closer to the 95
percent if you're doing five minutes is
closer to the eighty percent and you
have variable recovery it could be one
minute it could be five minutes but the
goal of high intensity interval training
is more of that anaerobic metabolic
conditioning to be able to sustain that
kind of really intense effort for a
little bit longer period of time
when we talk about Sprint interval
training that's different that's about a
central nervous system let's go all out
trying to get a true epigenetic change
within the muscle so we have better
glucose control we have better muscle
expression to handle stress so there are
two different things but all up a high
intensity interval training session
wouldn't be more than 35 minutes and
that's with a warm-up and a cool down
like 20-25 minutes of work really and
those in those 20 25 minutes are you
saying like hey I I'm only going for 30
seconds like I mean I can't Sprint the
same speed for 30 seconds so let's just
say I go all out for 30 seconds I'm
recovering for four minutes sometimes
yes three three minutes something like
that
yeah exactly if you're someone who's
like what that sounds awful then you
could do like a buy-in workout and
that's one of my one of my favorite ways
of explaining it is like you have 12
minutes and you're doing every other
minute of work and in that first minute
you're doing 10 deadlifts at 70 and then
as soon as you finish that you're
hopping on an ERG of some sort and
you're trying to accumulate as many
meters as you can for the rest of that
minute fully recover the next minute
then you do it again and the goal is to
get more meters each time so you want to
go faster and faster and faster usually
people hold about the same amount but
from a rating perceived exertion they
push themselves and they're fully gassed
and that is a true like high intensity
Sprint interval workout it's a good way
to get someone to actually tap out
because it's hard I was going to say
it's a difficult difficult marker
especially if you're not someone who's
been competitive in your life very much
to know what 80 95 percent looks like
most people never see 95 in their life
no because it's too uncomfortable like
I'm gonna vomit yep that's what we want
we want that feeling because that means
that you're really pushing yeah do you
have to sit down do you have to lay down
yeah that's pretty close then that's
good we like that yeah people are like
well you want to put older women and I'm
like yeah I do because that's what you
need really so tell me about that
because that's not something part of my
program right now so what what what
where does that where would that fit in
where does that fall so we're looking at
um how our estrogen progesterone changes
when we start to get into our 40s and
Beyond
the thing about estrogen is it's
responsible not only for stimulating our
muscle cell development our satellite
cell but it's also responsible for how
strong our muscle contraction is because
it it's responsible for how strong
myosin bonds binds to actin for that
muscle contraction and it also is
responsible for how much acetylcholine
is being held in the area where the
nerves come down and then hop the little
Gap Junction to like stimulate the
muscle contraction oh so when we start
to lose estrogen we lose power and we
lose strength
so this is where the first thing that
women notice as they're starting to get
closer and closer to menopause is like I
don't have power or speed or strength
anymore what's going on so this is where
your resistance training comes in
fantastic but we're looking at heavy
resistance training we're not looking at
those 8 to 15 reps no it's a blend of
strength and hypertrophy both okay so we
want a central nervous system tap in so
we want to actually create that
adaptation where the central nervous
system is doing what estrogen used to do
there's like okay that's the high
intensity no that's the heavy lift
that's the heavy lifting okay
so then when we look at high intensity
exercise we hear oh you shouldn't do
high intensity because it increases
cortisol and if we go back to those
definitions yes if you're doing those 45
minute classes then yes you're going to
get that increase in cortisol but if
you're doing true high intensity work
like we just talked about the Sprint
interval or the true high intensity you
get a boost of growth hormone a boost of
anti-inflammatory and oxidative
properties in a boost in your
testosterone so we're looking at helping
our bodies get healthier and maintain
better hormonal control we need to fit
in some Sprint interval and some true
high intensity so we say maybe two
Sprint interval sessions or one Sprint
and one high intensity with your
resistance training in a week it's not a
lot
and so the high intensity would be more
of your one to five minute sort of is it
something like a deadlift in a skier
kind of a routine versus or is that also
considered your high intensity
um cardio sort of training so if we're
going to do like the buy-in workout that
I just talked about the deadlifts and
the herb that fits in with your Sprint
interval because it's one minute of
lifting in 30 seconds as hard as you
think give me an example of uh of more
of a high intensity yeah so this would
be like getting on the skierg and
holding a 80 pace so maybe oh gosh
because I don't know how strong you are
on the ski York so I'd say like a one
minute 4500 but who knows you know so
you're holding a 500 meter pace for a
minute 30 and then you have a minute 30
off
to recover so it's a light active
recovery so you're just bringing the
heart rate down a little bit and then
it's just the level below Sprint yeah
just a little level below Sprint yeah so
you're 80 yeah hits more or Sprints more
of your 90 you know if we're gonna kind
of rank them it's like yeah you want to
be okay it's just a different level but
you can use the same actions yep they
just have different they're just
different timing yep a little bit lower
intensity and less recovery you got it I
got it and that also can be a 30 minute
session including a warm-up cooldown
kind of thing or yep exactly yep and how
long should your warm-up cooldown be for
those I usually say you take the first
10 minutes to like mobilize get it used
to the movement that you're gonna do so
if you're going to be doing deadlifts
you're doing a lot of hinging work
you're doing like good mornings with the
band so you're really getting into and
firing and getting all those muscles
ready to go and then for your cool down
it's all about let's really start to
bring that heart rate down flush out
muscles and then do some more
mobilization to make sure that you're
not going to stay crooked or you know
how your body falls when it starts to
get fatigued okay okay cool let me think
if there's any other workout questions
I think that's good is there anything
else you recommend for training
plyometrics
jump training yeah because we're looking
at bone health a lot of people were like
okay well I run that should be good for
my bones no we know that running isn't a
multi-directional stress it doesn't help
with bone health we need
some jumping so if we're looking at
Plyometrics it's twofold one it helps
with that Sprint interval it could be
counted as a Sprint interval I was just
going to ask because dude squat jumps
and things like that bra jumps I mean
you could you can die doing that stuff
yeah so jumping lunges yes exactly so
you can use that as your Sprint interval
but you want to have that jump component
for bone health
so we're looking at that
multi-directional stress from Landing
from the jump and that's like boom let's
keep those bones strong and healthy
[Music]
cool okay so those are the big ones yeah
um okay what about rest let's kind of
like bring it home a little bit with
that because that of all things oh
can't forget birth control since that's
something
um let's just finish up with sort of
training workout and then get into that
but
um
I never rested man ever I mean I've I I
just didn't I mean I think I even wrote
In the book like I rest days naturally
happened I was like you know you don't
plan them you're traveling you're
working whatever they just happen but I
now I would because I mean even on my I
basically work out I feel like three
days a week and the other three days are
such low intensity they don't feel
taxing whatsoever so I would say and and
I've had I had incredible biomarker
feedback by doing this for a month with
you know inflammation and you know true
like I did this treatment called Ebu
which is this Blood dialysis that Wicks
off inflammation it filters the blood
you can see what your oxidative stress
is like coming back into the arm after
it's been filtered and just with one
month of doing that I went from having
450 milliliters of inflammation come off
of my blood half of my blood to 150. I
went from being a able to handle the
ozone uh because it's when it's a 60
Minute process I I could only handle it
for 30 minutes and I could handle the
entire 60 without my blood being really
dark coming back into my other arm so
like I'm an I have been so far off with
recovery so far and it's one of those
under stated just like nutrition is
understated so often we think we can
outrun a bad diet well you can't outrun
recovery either because the whole like
like I keep coming back to you is like
why are you training you're training to
create a greater stress on the body so
the body's like I have to adapt to that
but if you never give it time to adapt
then you're always going to be in a
breakdown state if you're in a breakdown
State first thing that goes is lean mass
first thing that goes up is inflammation
and oxidation and we know none of those
are good and viable for health so we
look at not only for health but if
you're someone who's competitive or want
to do some kind of like 5K 10K whatever
it is CrossFit open who knows you need
recovery in order to debt and get fitter
so if we're looking at recovery metrics
it doesn't mean necessarily sitting on
your butt and doing nothing but it's
that polarized super low intensity work
because if you're doing true high
intensity and Sprint interval you need
recovery because you can't do that every
day you can't go to the gym and be like
I'm going to do this every day your body
just won't allow you and you're going to
fall into that modern intensity tired
but wired sympathetically driven your
body's going to break down you're going
to put on belly fat you're going to go
what the hell is going on recovery is so
essential and as we get older we find we
need more recovery we see though on that
women are more endurance so when we're
looking at fatigue ability and endurance
when we're doing reps and sets in our
resistance training we we don't need as
much recovery between because our bodies
our muscles our muscle architecture is
less fatigable than men so we need a
little bit more of a dose response to
get adaptation but when we talk about
recovery from day to day we start to see
women need a little bit more because we
don't have the same kind of muscle
enzymes for fast twitch that men do our
bodies need a little bit more time to
absorb that hard training recover from
it before we can hit it hard again so I
tend to tell people like if you're
looking at a week and you're someone
who's like I always have lots of energy
at the beginning of the week and then it
starts to taper off it's like okay well
let's moderate that let's do like a
Monday evening session and maybe a
Tuesday Morning session and then
Wednesdays off and then maybe a Thursday
evening session Fridays off and then you
might do something on the weekend and
when I say off I mean really low
intensity and when you're doing a
session that's like your resistance
training or your Sprint so it's you're
trying to really like polarize where
you're putting it giving your body
adequate recovery and the reason why
you're bookending a Monday night and a
Tuesday morning is so that Monday you're
sleeping in being able to deal with what
happens on a Monday and then you do your
hard session Monday night and then you
get another dose response by doing it
Tuesday morning so it compounds the
responses
better better stress some more there's
more adaptation needed because you've
kind of you put them so close together
but then you give yourself a bigger
block of a break yeah because then you
have all of twos the rest of Tuesday all
of Wednesday most of Thursday then you
hit Friday and then Friday is really
really hard again and your body can
handle it
yeah I'd be remiss though before I move
on to not ask about body recomposition
sort of puzzle of yeah like what's the
quickest way to do that to have a body
recomp and then I'm curious about like
bulking and cutting that's not something
that I've ever done I'm not sure it's
something I'd really love to do but it
seems like it's the sometimes the
quickest way to get certain results just
because you give yourself the adequate
nutrition to grow muscles but then have
sort of cuts so what's the what's the
most efficient way to
maintain and grow lean body mass but
then reduce body fat when we're looking
at you had the key factor there like
eating to build your muscle because so
many women don't eat enough and you need
abundance to actually build muscle right
so you're doing your heavy resistance
training and for women we know that when
you're doing heavy resistance training
especially like squats and deadlifts it
increases the mobilization of abdominal
fat so by the nature of actually doing
resistance training you're helping body
recomp so if you're doing your build
phase right and you're polarizing like I
just said like the double dose and then
another hard one so you can actually get
harder then we look strategically to do
one Sprint interval maybe on Wednesday
night
and we have a slight calorie restriction
every night so when we're looking at
what are we doing okay we're going to
take out maybe
150 to 200 calories every night but only
over the course of one block of training
so you build and you're like I gotta cut
okay how am I going to cut well we keep
our resistance training and we add in
one Sprint interval session to really
top in like create a dish a different
stress and then we have a very slight
calorie restriction so the lineup so
you're bulking and cutting within the
week yep
and then the other thing is really
upping that protein
so we see that when you're in a calorie
deficit if you are maintaining that 1.1
to 1.2 grams per pound
you strip body fat and you keep your
lean mass so women who are eating a lot
and they're like yeah I need protein
protein protein it's like it's really
hard pressed even with my Olympic
lifters they're still not eating enough
protein to get that muscle because it's
really hard to think about how much
protein you need to eat because they're
like what do you mean I need 150 to 160
grams a day it's like well that's what
you need to build it and to and to lose
some of the body fat so protein becomes
really important there is a study I've
been talking about recently because a
friend of mine from
um Flora he posted it and he's like look
at this really cool study on protein and
they took
um normal weight but obese women so you
know like skinny fat and there was this
big cohort and they split them and none
of them were doing exercise they're just
normal daily life they split them and
all they did was increase the protein
intake in one group to 1.6 grams per
kilo so that's just right around that
0.8 to 0.9 grams yeah and then the the
other group maintained their normal
which was like 0.8 grams per kilo so
what is that point
five per pound ish or maybe a little bit
less over the course of 12 weeks no
exercise people with a higher protein
intake completely recomp their body no
exercise same calories too same calories
okay got it they just no calorie change
macro adjustment yep exactly
so protein is so powerful when you're
bumping it up and your body's like oh
look at this I can build lean mass I
don't need to store fat because I can
build leaves I have the building blocks
yes exactly
so you know we talk about exercise and
resistance training being the key all
but if you don't have adequate protein
you're not going to maximize that and
you're not going to recomp
so protein super important so you talked
about a calorie deficit just on the days
where you're not training essentially of
sort of one or two hundred calories what
does it do if you stay in a slight
calorie deficit not too much of a
calorie deficit but your training is
sort of spread out is there is that just
like a less effective way can you even
recomp if you if you don't have adequate
amount of calories for the work that
you're doing are you just defeating the
whole purpose yes that's the short
answer yes because as I was talking
about earlier right if you don't have
enough stuff coming in then your
hypothalamus is like Hey we're in a
survival mode I better start putting
stuff on and down regulating the thyroid
to conserve conserve conserve and have
endocrine dysfunction if you are
bookending your workouts with really
adequate nutrition then you have a
slight calorie deficit that's something
different but a lot of people aren't on
to it that much so they're like oh
calorie deficit I'm just not going to
eat that many calories or I'm going to
skip this or I'm going to skip that and
so they end up in too much of a calorie
deficit and they don't actually pay
attention to how they're fueling in
around their training if a really
specific then we can make sure that
we're getting enough carbohydrate and
enough protein in around training to
support that and to tell the
hypothalamus yeah yeah we got enough and
then look okay here's a slight calorie
deficit of maybe 100 calories on the
days that we train on the days that we
don't train maybe we're bumping it to
150 200 but it's always in the evening
so that your body's not like hey wait
what's going on right and so
low impact steady state stuff is not
considered
um uh one of your training days correct
right if you're going out for like an
hour and a half then yeah it's going to
be fuel depleting even if it is super
low steady state so that would be part
of your calorie deficit if you are going
out for 45 minutes to an hour it's 50 or
less of of your Max Capacity and it's
just kind of like moving then no that's
just moving and then as far as for those
people who don't consume animal protein
like yourself what what are your best
tips to get enough protein wide variety
wide variety of fruits veggies I know
people like what veggies protein peas
green peas lots of protein in there
right and Nami we look at nuts and seeds
we look at sprouted grain breads Bread's
good especially a lot of protein and
sprouted green breads tempeh for
fermentation I'm not a fan of tofu
primarily because I can't handle soy but
I don't find it a really fantastic
source of protein I'd rather err on the
side of tempeh because you have more
bang for your body we're looking at
nutrient density
um and then yeah and there's times and
places when you're really trying to up
your protein where you have to
supplement and that's just part of it
like you can't eat enough
yeah yeah yeah yeah so don't be afraid
to implement it it's there to use let's
finish off with just sort of like a
little bit of a wake-up call of the of
birth for birth control because I feel
like it's one of those things that in
the general population is getting a lot
of awareness to its
um detriment everything from uh you know
disrupting you're not having a real
cycle and having a withdrawal bleed
which I didn't even know until a few
years ago
um because I took birth control for 16
years
um to every to even
studies showing that women that are on
contraceptive oral contraceptive or
birth control are choosing different men
than if they weren't on birth control
they choose more feminine men when
they're on birth control than when
they're off so essentially if you've got
a if you if your woman is on birth
control you're together and then she
gets off of it she might not like you
yep I know strange isn't it it is and I
always think about the poor side effect
of it reducing testosterone correct it
reduces testosterone in in women as well
which I think I took it for my whole
career so essentially this is what was
happening with my much needed like
my job yeah like when we look at
OCS and the combined oral contraceptive
pill right so when we look at it there's
so many different formulations
when we're looking at the progestin
component that's the important part this
is where we start to see that you have a
lot of aggression depending on what if
it's more androgenic so this is why the
studies are coming out it's like if a
woman's on an OC and she's looking for a
more effeminate man it's because she
feel the androgenicity of that progestin
is making her like really aggressive and
it's like yeah okay I want to be the
alpha in the in the relationship here
we look from performance metrics and we
look at the estrogen and the
progesterone component so we know that
if someone is using a 30 microgram dose
of estradiol in their oral contraceptive
pill it builds Muscle really easily but
there's no strength that accompanies
that muscle bulk weird so it's like why
do I want to build more muscle fibers
when it doesn't actually make me
stronger if we look at 20 microgram dose
it doesn't really do anything different
than naturally cycling
we look at oxidative stress it's much
higher just across the board for women
who are taking oral contraceptive pill
we see inflammation factors much higher
for women using it across the board
and we also see that screening
schematics change so we know that if we
are looking at training really really
hard it's the first five days of the
active fill where you can push hard and
recover well
and it's the last five days of the
placebo pill that you can train really
really hard and recover well because
when you're on it it's not like you have
this steady state dose you have a peak
and a trough every day which is why 10
days from the start of your bleed
essentially ish until five days in five
days after ish yep because you have this
accumulation of hormones and that's how
it works to like suppress your own
ovarian hormones and with each
subsequent day of increasing those
active hormones knowing that the
estradiol component is 500 times greater
on the cellular level than your natural
production what does that mean so that
means that every time you take a pill
and it accumulates you're getting a
greater and greater and greater negative
response on a cell level from these
hormones because we have receptors
everywhere in our body
and so that's why we're finding there's
less power availability for training it
blunts Sprint adaptation it Blends down
Road capacity and and we're seeing that
from a neuromuscular and fatigability
standpoint there are certain times
during the oral contraceptive pill where
you just like can't do it
so when I'm working with someone like do
you really need to be on combined oral
contraceptive pill or can we look at
something like the IUD because we're
using an IUD even if it's a marina with
a little bit of progestin you still
ovulate so you can still track your
cycle you don't have this great systemic
effects and if you're like nah I don't
want to use an IUD then maybe we look at
like the vaginal ring or an estradiol
patch something that's an original ring
that's what I used yeah it's great oh
really was that like a good option then
yeah because it's more of a localized
dose right so you're looking at
localized dose it's not as systemic and
it's because when you are looking at how
your body metabolizes and uses hormones
when it naturally produces it it goes to
the liver first and it gets bound up by
sex hormone binding globulin that then
gets excreted into the intestines
through bile then your little gut bugs
are like oh let's unbind it and kick it
back out and then you have estrogen
progesterone testosterone that work for
you when you're taking an oral
contraceptive pill it doesn't go to the
liver it doesn't have that hepatic pass
so it goes into the digestive system and
you only have 25 percent bioavailability
which is why the doses are so high
and because you don't have that control
through the liver it's very arbitrary of
how women are going to respond to it of
course there's going to be ovarian
suppression but you don't know
necessarily how the other systems are
going to be affected that's why we're
really starting to dig in and be like
okay what is 20 versus 30 doing is that
is there anything to do with like
detoxification Pathways is that sort of
like like glutathione would sort of
change the trajectory of the
bioavailability or how much gets
delivered how fast it gets to you how
much
yeah and also the Sip Gene because you
know your liver is responsible for all
the detox and all those Pathways so if
it doesn't hit the liver then yeah your
body has to be like oh what else do I do
with this thing
um and a lot of the original research on
OCS wasn't done on women either so we're
looking at male rats and then we had
some male test subjects so even their
metabolism is different so all in all
like the origins of the OC Great you
know because it gave women more
empowerment and Reproductive Rights but
then when you look retrospectively
you're like that's another way to
control women because it's really
downgrading their natural system so
that's why I'm like look vaginal ring it
is just localized how do you just
localized and we're looking at the
localization of those hormones and the
effect just on the on the cervix and the
reap and the mucosal membrane it's all
about like barrier to sperm it's not
about changing your ovarian hormone
responses or anything like that so it
but is there still is it still just a
withdrawal bleed though with the vaginal
Ring versus the IUD
no you just don't ovulate when we're
looking at the vaginal ring when you
first put it in it can suppress
ovulation and then as like you get to
the third week your body's like oh I can
I can possibly ovulate so it's Hit or
Miss depending on how long you've used
it there's more and ovulatory Cycles on
the vaginal ring with the IUD it's about
eight months after insertion then you
start ovulating again so it's yeah but
the systemic effects are different wow
wow high five myself good work that's
good
um okay I mean I feel like that covers
quite a bit of it I mean you're just
such a wealth of knowledge and I just
appreciate your
all your information it's just there's
just not that many there's just not that
many people that are not that many women
and I think it really takes women
because it takes a passion for
understanding it to really be as
comprehensive as you are so thank you
for sharing so many so so much truth
around how we work and is is there a
place in the future where there should
be more women used in these studies I
mean I feel like what I heard was that
because of reproductive years it's it's
been dangerous to use women because it
could affect that so that's a lot of
times why women weren't used in some of
the studies but is that like
why is it that the studies are so bad
yeah so when we look at the
modernization of medicine and scientific
design it was a point where men were
like women are have smaller brains and
they're delicate flowers and they don't
know anything so when we look at like
how things evolved it's all been through
that male lens so scientific design has
always been through the male lens and I
mean it was a point not too long ago
where women going through perimenopause
or putting insane asylums because no one
understood what was going on
and if you look retrospectively almost
all the women that were killed as
witches in the Salem Witch Hunt were
women who were perimenopausal because of
hot flashes and mood disorders so people
like primarily men are like these women
are crazy and they're witches so there's
a long history of the male lens on all
of this stuff so we look specifically at
scientific design originally it was male
rats and it was CIS men and that model
is broken people are seeing that it's
broken we see things like Ambien you
know it stays in a women's system a lot
longer so people like gosh what the hell
so medical community even though it was
like in the 90s that NIH said you can't
just use male rats you can't just use
men but it's just in the past four to
five years where people like oh my gosh
yeah really we have to use women and I
will say one benefit of the covid
pandemic is the outcomes between women
and men in the vaccine and the vaccine
rates and success in the vaccine what
was that I don't even know that
statistic it was better for women women
got less sick and they had less time
being sick than men and then they're
looking now at long covid and
unfortunately it's reversed but now
people are really going what's going on
if that happened then there are sex
differences so if if it was not that
case if men did better than women never
would have been the conversation but
because women did better than men on the
vaccine it made so many people globally
in the medical community look up and be
like what
and then in sports science and nutrition
I've been in this for oh gosh a couple
of decades but it's really just been in
the past four or five years where we've
had you know like Don Scott who's been
tracking menstrual cycle on the U.S
soccer team coming out and saying hey
we've had better outcomes when we're
tracking the menstrual cycle and people
are like what what do you mean and so
it's been feeding forward back into the
scientific Community you have to clean
up that scientific design and include
women no longer as a peer reviewer am I
going to like yell at the assistant
editor that they passed me a paper that
said we excluded women because they have
a menstrual cycle I was like that is not
an appropriate exclusion you send it
desk rejection so now we're seeing more
desk rejections for that
um so it's getting better we still have
a long way to go yeah and obviously you
know just to touch on it just because
it's something that's been part of my
puzzle piece was and I feel like it's
just more prevalent in women and I'm
wondering if you've seen anything in
your field dealing with so many women
um probably less because of the nature
of what they're doing but I had breast
implants for seven and a half years and
had those removed and definitely think
that was part of my endocrine disruptor
and suppression of hormones thyroid gut
health so many different things is that
anything that has caught your radar or
um yeah it's the materials used for sure
and we see that and we also see it in
implants for Prosthetics like hip
replacements and knee Replacements yeah
because again all of it's been done on
male data even breast implants like male
data where they're looking at wood I
know so they're looking at like when we
start it and we got to make sure the
efficacy is safe and they started it on
mail rats so they didn't take it because
they you know it's pretty steady so
let's just use male rats and then when
it gets into like the clinical trials of
course they're using women but the
original efficacy data stemmed from male
rats I'm sure they lived long enough to
show the results I'm sure
all right well so much to so much to
digest and use and better ourselves but
then also so many so many areas that
still improved so thank you thank you so
much for taking the time from all the
way across the world yeah no thanks for
having me it's been fun chatting thanks
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button